[Musique]
voilà monsieur bonjour dans le cadre de
sa aux cadis consacrée aux élections
municipales
après les candidats nous recevons les
représentants du monde économique social
sportif et culturel
bonjour et en hesse les risques bonjour
alain vous est ce que le secrétaire
général adjoint de la cgtm soem des
employés multiples et des collectivités
donc quelle est la situation dix
employés municipaux en martinique les la
situation des employés
elle peut être diverses en fonction des
collectivités nous avons différence
forme de statut nous avons des collègues
qui sont déjà titularisé pour lequel les
uns des moments de carrière qui se fait
tout naturellement
et puis des collègues qui sont en quête
de le devenir parce qu'ils sont encore
dans des phases iii de cdi soit d'aidés
sur la solide et évidemment au regard de
la campagne aux attentes sont diverses
très bien on va voir les attentes mais
justement on va en parler qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez attendre de ces élections
ce qu'on peut attendre des élections et
nous représentants du personnel c'est
d'abord de porter des messages au plus
haut niveau poids de nos députés
jusqu'aux nomination d'anne au
gouvernement de sorte à nous faire
entendre sur nos préoccupations sur la
retraite ça n'y a pas d'ambiguïté c'est
c'est l'objectif phare de l'album
d'abord la retraite alors qu'est ce qui
pose problème sur la retraite parce que
ces sites d'actualités d'ailleurs nous
aurions tellement de messages à faire
passer à l'ensemble de la population
mais pour rester au niveau de ce qui se
passe dans le monde de la territoriale
nous nous concertons nous 60 ans les
premiers concernés les premiers impactés
et c'est à dire c'est effectivement
notre régime particulier nous a pas des
avantages tels le tiers d'eau mien le
tien demain vient compenser toute
éventuelle décote qu'on pourrait avoir
sur le déroulement de carrière chez vous
savez lorsque l'agent il arrive en
collectivité ou yann c'est un parcours
du combattant des fois il commence à
travailler à trente ans et au moment se
présenter à la retraite au moment de
l'ouverture de ses doigts il se pourrait
que dans la cale dans le calcul de
formules manque des trimestres
eh bien nous au niveau de notre test
nous avons l'avantagé d'avoir ce qui
s'appelle le tir domiens ça veut dire
quand vous cotisez trois ans vous offre
4 ça veut dire que quand vous cotisez 30
ans est bien derrière c'est l'équivalent
de 40 années de cotisation et ça
effectivement ça veut compenser pour
nous une décote et avec la retraite fait
le le le
la loi que prévoit le gouvernement vous
allez voir tous là disparaître le
gouvernement ne nous demande pas notre
avis le gouvernement des sens des
propositions ils ne parlent que de re
prêtent pas à point c'est quoi nous est
pas un point mais vous capitaliser des
points et où vont être parti à la
retraite
on vous restitue mais tous ces avantages
évidemment tous ces avantages
jamais ils ne vont en parler puisque
dans l'objectif il ya qu'à l'origine
s'est économisé donc ils savent pas
disparaître bien sûr alors dans la
campagne des municipales vous allez
mettre en avant ce thème des retraites
notamment au niveau des mers oui au
niveau des mers mais aussi au niveau des
espaces communautaires établissements
publics et/ou oui c'est d'abord à nous
élus de le faire passer ses messages
même si nous avons effectivement
mobiliser les agents au niveau dans les
oui mais derrière ils nous demandent de
faire remonter ce message jusqu'au
gouvernement ça veut dire aux preneurs
de décisions et de les convictions tout
alors qu'elle vient autres comment dire
centres d'intérêt que vous avez quels
sont vos autres revendications
lot 3 400 force et la titularisation
un agent qui met les pieds dans une
collectivité son objectif c'est un jour
d'athènes ce sacre qui est d'être
titularisé puisque effectivement à
partir du moment où vous utilisez vous
vous devenez pleinement fonctionné
statutairement et effectivement c'est à
ce moment là qu'il ya un maximum
davantage et tout le travail qui a été
fautif y est pour arriver à cela c'est à
ce moment là qu effectivement là du
résultat
combien de temps ça prend une
titularisation légalement ça le point
d'une année une année juste une période
de socialisation
mais bon dans en métropole allez en haut
en deux ans c'est fait mais chez
malheureusement chez nous je pense que
ça doit être à cause d'un handicap de
40% à ajouter sur le traitement
indiciaire est effectivement en moyenne
il faut compter 7 8 ans mais vous savez
qu'il ya des gens qui laisse quand même
20 ans bloqué dans le statut de
contractuel et qui finalement pour
lesquels il n'y aura plus d'intérêt de
ce faire tu la risée l'iccat pour cent
sont frais à la titularisation il faut
être honnête je le pense je le pense je
voulais supprimés alors
ah ben non pas du tout au contraire moi
je suis convaincu qu'on devrait faire
tout ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir apporter
même pas seulement 40 % jusqu'à 50 55%
d'après mes calculs à l'ensemble de la
population de la martinique et des dom
oui mais ça veut dire que si on apporte
50 55 sicav car on sent déjà du mal à
titulariser on va plus pouvoir
titulariser c'est un autre débat on
n'aura pas le temps de débattre
aujourd'hui les richesses sont là le
fouiller la faut vous dire que chaque
petites mains qui a produit qui a fait
grandir un bébé dans une crèche il ya 15
ou 20 ans qui sont devant ses enfants
soient devenus des ingénieurs ils ont
produit des recettes proue de cette
condition profite à la société mais où
elle va et huelva où elle va le résultat
de cette production est bien derrière si
effectivement il y avait une bonne
répartition des richesses nous aurions
pas eu du mal à subventionner les
emplois actuels mentionné rice est ce
que les employés municipaux est ce que
vous ce que les syndicats sont
sollicités par les candidats sollicité
par les candidats je ne vais pas dire ça
ce serait malhonnête par contre oui
effectivement en période de précampagne
effectivement c'est le moment de porter
nos revendications et effectivement nous
sommes entendus puisque je suppose que
il n'est pas question de crier des
vagues
donc effectivement nous avons des tables
de revendications en cours et
effectivement sur ces moments là nous
sommes encore plus forts et plus
déterminés vous passez dans chaque
mairie déposer des revendications ce
moment ça ne se passe pas comme ça il ya
déjà des travaux en cours des tables de
revendications et effectivement ils
n'ont nous nous donne nous exigions mais
c'est normal aussi nous exigeons des
réponses puisque voilà si le candidat si
le méprisant houleux
le directeur d'établissement ou alors le
président d'une collectivité n'est pas
ce matin n'est pas renouvelée
effectivement tout tout le travail qui
est mis en place avec lui est perdu est
ce que vous regardez les programmes des
candidats
je crois qu'en personnellement puisque
ça c'est un droit que m'apporte la
constitution maintenant je n'ai pas
d'avis à donner en tous cas ça ne pas
vous seulement mais je parle du jeu
parce que vous êtes aussi porte parole
des deux d'un ensemble de personnes en
somme de daddy rend et voilà donc à ce
que les employés municipaux regarde et
sont attentifs mais bien sûr que
proposent les candidats mais bien sûr
mais bien sûr parce que c'est la
personne se sent trop milieu au milieu
tout évidemment c'est son devenir qui
lui importe d'abord donc notamment les
agents qui sont contractuels qu'ils
soient en cdi ou qui sont qu'ils soient
qu'ils sont en phase d'être que d'avoir
un cdi ou alors qu'ils mettent les pieds
évidemment s'ils ont un petit contrat et
qui sauf qu'il n'est pas suffisamment
ancrées ils ont peur de voir leurs
contrats non renouvelés donc qui joue
comme cela particulièrement raconte dans
le déroulement de carrière aussi de
certains des promesses ou alors des
procédures engagées qui n'ont pas abouti
mais effectivement ça génère une
certaine crainte ou angoisse en tout cas
en fonction de la nouvelle mandature
vous êtes vous êtes vous êtes
vous êtes attentifs aux promesses de
campagne notamment direction des
personnels
nous sommes attentifs mais moi si j'ai
un message à faire passer c'est de dire
clairement aux candidats attention
attention à ce que vous promettez parce
que notamment pour un candidat qui
arrive
les candidats qui sont déjà en place qui
vont renouveler une connexion
l'expérience mais il faut pas promettre
du n'importe quoi parce qu'effectivement
à cause justement de toutes ces
restrictions budgétaires de la notamment
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
il faut reconnaître que effectivement
les maires et les présidents des espaces
communautaires
ils ont un peu de difficulté à mettre en
place leur action politique
justement c'était là c'était la
prochaine question
une crainte par rapport à ces dotations
financières qui diminuent
vous avez parlé de la dgf la dotation
globale de fonctionnement
il ya aussi des mairies qui connaissent
un certain nombre qui sont épinglés tout
simplement par lasser assez la chambre
régionale des comptes
est ce que ça vous génère une certaine
crainte vous ça génère une certaine
crainte évidemment puisque derrière nous
savons que la qualité du service public
en prend un coup
ça c'est clair après derrière et ben
écoute et qu'on n'y a pas d'argent
l'argent c'est le nerf de la guerre donc
rien ne peut se développer et derrière
lorsque l'agent pas à la retraite ou est
malade
eh bien il n'est pas remplacé et nous
nous retrouvons avec des collègues qui
sont obligés d'effectuer le travail de
trois personnes vous voyez donc
évidemment que j'agirais des craintes
quant à cancun mairie est épinglée par
la crc la chambre régionale des comptes
est-ce que vous syndicats vous
travailler main dans la main avec le
maire est ici service pour éviter que
qu'on arrive par exemple à des
licenciements ou bien des fermetures de
postes bien sûr nous n'avons pas le
choix nous sommes obligés de faire des
propositions
nous sommes obligés d'attendre qu'ils
nous appellent et nous asseyons 1 sur
une table et nous aussi nous faisons des
propositions dans tous les sens nous
proposons des pôles l'économie ça va de
soi ça valoir sa bleue soit bien sûr
alors dernière question si vous aviez un
message à délivrer aux candidats de ces
municipales ce serait lequel
mais écoutez je suis modeste je ne sais
pas quoi leur dire puisqu'ils sont très
ambitieux mais je le dis mais attention
pensez opérationnel ne parlait pas de
charges salariales parce que le mot
charge ses palmes au bon je préfère le
thème cotisation mais effectivement les
travailleurs sont là pour voir nos
services publics ils ne demandent que ça
le monde à être formés être accompagnés
et aaron service public donc tenez vos
engagements et 1 sd ris je vous remercie
cette émission a été réalisée par
pauline tout ça